more than 200,000 people have died in
the Syrian civil war
since 2011 one of the deadliest weapons
used in the war is the barrel bomb and
it's used by the Assad regime barrel
bombs are oil drums packed with
explosives fuel and metal fragments this
crude unguided weapon is typically
dropped from helicopters onto homes
hospitals schools and places of worship
the result a massive explosion and
indiscriminate death in the first three
months of 2015
barrel bombs killed at least three
thousand 124 civilians the UN has banned
the use of barrel bombs and the Assad
regime denies using them and yet human
rights groups say the government
increasingly relies on the weapon so if
barrel bomb attacks are so deadly why do
they get hardly any attention
since the conflict began 2.9 million
Syrians have fled the country and more
than 6.5 million have become internally
displaced